ستيفاني من نيويورك الذي يكتب لك
يعرف كيف نمضي قدمًا مع العلم أن
العديد من الأمريكيين لن يتم تطعيمهم أبدًا
حتى مع الحصول على
موافقة إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) الكاملة في أي مرحلة يصبح كوفيد
فيروسًا مستوطنًا يجب أن نتعلم كيف
نتعايش معه دون قيود كبيرة في
مدارسنا  والحياة الطبيعية
بشكل جيد ؛ أعتقد أنك تعرف من حيث
المتوطنة بمعنى أن الفيروس موجود
ليبقى ، أعتقد أنه من المحتمل أن نقول إنه
الآن فيروس معدي حقًا
وأنت تعلم أن هناك
أحفاد إنفلونزا 1918 أو الأشياء
التي نحن  ما زلت أعيش معك
بعد مرور أكثر من 100 عام ، لذلك هذا
ممكن تمامًا ولكن قد يكون
نوعًا غير منطقي من رفيق السكن إذا كنت
ستحمله كثيرًا ، إليك ما قاله الدكتور
فوسي قبل بضعة أيام فقط إذا كان
بإمكاننا فعل ذلك مع الأشخاص الذين
لقد أصيبوا بإعادة تطعيم
الأشخاص الذين لم يتم تطعيمهم الآن بعد أن تم تطعيم 90
مليون
شخص لهم وأعتقد أنه يمكننا الحصول على
درجة من الحماية الشاملة من
المجتمع الذي ندخل فيه
الجزء الأول من عام 2022 خلال
فصل الشتاء والذي يمكن أن يكون معقدًا بسبب
الإنفلونزا بسبب فيروس الجهاز التنفسي المخلوي
الذي مع حلول فصل الربيع يمكننا
أن نبدأ في العودة إلى درجة من
الحياة الطبيعية ،
ما من المرجح أن يحدث هو  هذا بالإضافة
إلى التطعيمات كما نعلم ،
لأن هذا فيروس معدٍ
، يصاب الناس بالعدوى بشكل متزايد ،
إنها طريقة أكثر صعوبة
لتحقيق المناعة ولكن هناك
شيء يمكن قوله عن المناعة الطبيعية
لا تريد أن تفعل هذا أنا  لا
نشجعه لأن الناس يمرضون حقًا
ويمكن أن يموتوا ،
ولكن في تركيبة المناعة الطبيعية للقاح ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو ما
يشير إليه الدكتور فوشي بحلول الوقت
الذي نصل فيه إلى الربيع ، سوف
ينفد الفيروس من الأماكن للذهاب لأن هناك
ما يكفي  حصانة هناك